Public Sénat et écho DDS vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend l'écho
responsable sur Public Sénat smartphone
ordinateur télévision la vaisselle ou
encore lave-linge aujourd'hui on vous
parle de l'indice de réparabilité qui
accompagne nos appareils du quotidien 2
ans après son lancement quel bilan il
distributeur affiche-t-il bien cet
indice les marques ont-elles plus
d'efforts dans leur processus de
fabrication le consommateur est-il plus
enclin aujourd'hui à réparer qu'à
acheter et bien réponse avec le
président de l'association alt à
l'obsolescence programmée pour relever
ce défi de la réparation disposons
d'Asset de main d'oeuvre et d'accès aux
pièces détachées reportage à suivre dans
cette émission enfin focus sur l'un des
plus gros acteurs de l'électrique et de
l'électronique qui n'a pas attendu cet
indice pour se lancer Enrique et
Martinez le patron de Fnac Darty sera
avec nous dans cette émission mais
d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
certains disent de réparabilité en moins
d'une minute c'est parti l'indice de
réparabilité c'est quoi au juste prévu
dans la loi anti-gaspillage il concerne
cinq familles un produit les smartphones
les ordinateurs portables les télés les
lave-linge à hublots et les tondeuses à
gazon et depuis novembre 2022 les
lave-vaisselles les aspirateurs les
lave-linge qui se chargent sur le dessus
et enfin les nettoyeurs haute pression
et comment il fonctionne comme à l'école
nos appareils sont notés de 1 à 10 avec
pour nous aider des codes couleurs du
vert foncé pour les bons élèves au rouge
vif pour les cancres cette note elle est
établie en fonction de 5 critères dont
l'accès à la documentation technique le
caractère démontable du produit la
disponibilité ou le prix des pièces
détachées et cette note on la trouve
partout les fabricants doivent en
principe fournir cette note au
distributeur qui eux ont l'obligation de
l'afficher en magasin et sur Internet à
côté du prix s'ils ne le font pas il
s'exposent depuis le 1er janvier 2022 à
des sanctions financières mais dans les
faits 52% des établissements ne
respectent pas la loi il est français
eux ils sont prêts à réparer plutôt qu'à
racheter pour l'instant
seul 36% répare leurs appareils quand
ils tombent en panne avec l'indice de
réparabilité le gouvernement espère
atteindre un taux de réparation de 60%
en 2026 pour aider les ménages un bonus
de réparation a été instauré le 15
décembre dernier
[Musique]
quel bilan pour l'indice de réparabilité
2 ans après sa création est-ce qu'il a
fait évoluer les comportements des
consommateurs mais aussi des fabricants
bonjour quand un gecker bonjour merci
d'être là avec nous vous êtes le
président de l'association hop alt à
l'obsolescence programmée c'est un
indice vous connaissez bien puisque vous
avez œuvrer sa création au côté de
l'État et de tous les acteurs d'ailleurs
concernés il faut le dire quel bilan on
peut en tirer déjà côté distributeur
est-ce que tout le monde joue le jeu ou
pas vraiment bah justement c'est une
très bonne question on a rendu un
rapport en octobre dernier pour montrer
enfin pour justement savoir si les
fabricants jouaient ou pas le jeu et
cette enquête compléter une enquête de
la DGCCRF qui avait qui a eu été rendu
le 27 septembre dernier et qui montre
que non
50% des distributeurs affichés pas
l'indice de réparabilité à date donc en
septembre nous on a montré en octobre
qu'on était même encore plus haut sur
les sur les distributeurs qu'on avait
contrôlé on était autour de 60% sur les
catégories un produit qui était à leur
en vigueur du coup c'était smartphone
ordinateur lave-linge hublot et j'en
oublie toujours un c'est lequel en tout
cas les étiquettes ne sont pas
suffisamment loin de là afficher dans
les rayons pourtant les vendeurs ont
l'obligation les distributeurs de
retirer les produits depuis janvier 2021
et depuis un an j'en ai 2022 il s'expose
même à des sanctions de la part de la
répression des fraudes et dans les faits
il y a pas évidemment bah alors pour
l'instant nous on n'a pas connaissance
d'amande qui ont été infligées pourtant
bah oui elle s'expose à des amendes 3000
euros pour une personne physique 15000
euros si c'est une personne morale
d'ailleurs on a et ça reste très
théorique je veux dire pour l'instant
oui c'était vrai mais justement nous ce
qu'on veut ce qu'on veut faire c'est que
c'est d'appeler à la responsabilité de
cette distributeurs c'est pour ça qu'on
a fait une action coup de poing en
novembre dernier à l'entrée en vigueur
sur les nouvelles sur les nouvelles
catégories de produits pour dire que
c'est pas possible ça suffit pas qu'il
faut aller plus loin et si cette
responsabilité collective des
distributeurs des vendeurs en fait sur
qui sur qui pèse
sur lesquels on veut alerter en tout cas
il faudrait que la répression des fautes
façon boulot aussi qu'elle fasse
appliquer la loi effectivement c'est
notre appel c'est qu'on veut que la
DGCCRF renforce ses contrôles pour créer
un effet de mouvement en fait que
derrière les vendeurs se disent ah bah
oui on peut pas être impuni pour ça
c'est une vraie obligation qui pèse sur
nous même si c'est nouveau même si on a
des excuses bah en fait c'est la loi il
faut la respecter ça c'est ce qu'on veut
après distributeur et fabricant se
renvoie un petit peu la balle sur les
responsabilités effectivement il y a pas
d'enquête pour le moment qui montre que
la faute incombe particulièrement
fabriquant ou particulièrement dissé par
en fait l'enquête de la DGCCRF qui a été
menée et notre enquête à nous a montré
que ça pouvait être à la fois affiché
sur le site des fabricants mais pas chez
les distributeurs des fois chez les
distributeurs les pas chez les
fabricants donc en fait il y a un
gloubi-boulgal là dedans et on veut
faire en sorte de d'éclaircir la
situation on appelait en fait la
responsabilité collective peu importe
que la que ce soit la faute du fabricant
à ce stade ou du vendeur quel rôle aussi
est là pour le coup pour les pouvoirs
publics
l'état évidemment un rôle à jouer lors
du Forum de la durabilité en novembre
dernier Bérengère Couillard la miss la
secrétaire d'État chargée de l'écologie
a annoncé justement à qu'une enquête
nationale allait être menée merci de
m'avoir un peu sifflet siffler le mot
c'est exactement ce qui s'est ce qui
s'est passé alors maintenant à ce stade
on n'a pas à de plus d'éléments sur ce
que va comporter cette enquête nationale
en tout cas nous on veillera à ce que
cette enquête soit une réelle avancée
une réelle poussée et pour savoir si à
la fin c'est du lard ou du cochon ça va
voir si c'était un effet d'annonce et
qu'à la fin c'est juste un coup de fil à
la dire à la déchetterie CRF aussi y
avoir des ressources supplémentaires
pour le contrôle le lundi on a parlé des
distributeurs il faut parler des
fabricants et comment est-ce qu'il note
est-ce qu'il note correctement leurs
produits parce que on en vient au choix
des critères évidemment pour établir ces
notes il y a cinq critères tout se
valent or certains critères et je vous
laisse parler sont plus importants que
d'autres ce qu'on a montré c'est qu'en
général les fabricants se surnotes de
on se dit qu'on ça devient vite école
des fleurs elles ont une grille de
critères à respecter quand même donc
elles sont quand même reste enfin elles
sont critères c'est ça elles sont
contraintes sous cette grille qu'elle
doivent publier mais c'est une synthèse
en fait et donc du coup il y a des
marges d'interprétation qui permettent
pas de dire si oui ou non à la fin on
était sur une une note voilà qui était
on était à 7 en fait on est à 8 sauf que
dans le comportement du consommateur
c'est c'est très c'est très différent
d'avoir cette nous ce qu'on dit c'est
que l'indice il est perfectible
aujourd'hui il est il est perfectible
dans à bien des égards notamment sur la
pondération c'est pas normal que toutes
les notes par effet de compensation
puisse être puisse se relever les unes
les autres je prends un exemple la
démontabilité des produits c'est hyper
important c'est le plus important à quoi
ça sert d'avoir des pièces détachées à
un prix abordable si on peut pas vous
pouvez même pas ouvrir votre appareil
sans le casser du coup et en fait
pourquoi on attribuerait du coup une
bonne note un appareil qui est même pas
des montable ce qui est possible
aujourd'hui d'être réalisé avec l'indice
de réparabilité donc nous ce qu'on a ce
qu'on veut faire c'est de faire relever
c'est il y a plusieurs options possibles
mais on veut un système de pondération
un meilleur système par exemple
la démontabilités serait une condition
sinequanone côté consommateur maintenant
cette réparabilité est-ce que c'est
devenu je me disais un vrai critère
d'achat pris en compte au début au même
titre que le prix ou que la performance
du produit alors il faut qu'on mette à
jour nos données mais effectivement au
1er mars 2022 c'est indice était connu
d'environ 50% des consommateurs qu'on
avait interrogé et dans trois quarts des
cas pour eux c'était un indice qui était
extrêmement utile du coup bah on montre
que oui oui il a une utilité et c'est en
d'autant plus important
et c'est d'autant plus important
aujourd'hui que le consommateur avant
aucun indice sur la réparabilité il
pouvait pas savoir si l'appareil qu'il a
acheté était réparable ou pas à moins de
se farfouiller dans des détails
techniques qui n'étaient pas accessible
au grand public et c'est ce que permet
aujourd'hui c'est indice il y a l'acte
d'achat puis après il y a le moment où
l'article produit tombe en panne est-ce
que les gens aujourd'hui réparent plus
c'est où est-ce qu'ils vont toujours se
rabattre malheureusement sur un sur un
produit neuf il y a une prise de
conscience et me dire oui mais après ce
qu'il y a est-ce qu'on est à l'étape
d'après au passage à l'acte justement là
il y a encore beaucoup de travail à
faire ouais ouais on est au début là
effectivement enfin lundi j'aurais pas
il monte si ce sera la parade ou pas il
y a pas encore d'études qui peuvent
montrer il faut encore un peu de temps
avant de montrer si lundi de
réparabilité a eu un effet sur
l'ensemble des produits concernés sur la
réparation il y a ce qu'il y a d'autres
facteurs en fait qui rentre en ligne de
compte pour savoir si on va pouvoir
réparer le prix le prix psychologique
enfin un frein psychologique lié au prix
ça coûte cher mieux vaut acheter un neuf
vous êtes très bien renseigné
effectivement il y a un frein
psychologique
30% effectivement c'est l'ADEME vous
montrer ça que au dessus de 30%
généralement quand le consommateur se
redirige vers un achat de neuf ou un
achat d'un nouveau produit en tout cas
c'est le cas souvent bah alors justement
si 80 78% des Européens soit être
réparer leurs produits plutôt que d'en
acheter un neuf ça c'est une étude de
remettre mais seulement dans les faits
36% le font donc on voit qu'il y a un
fossé encore qui est assez énorme et
qu'on a encore du mal à combler et
ensuite c'est indice de réparabilité
infini là-dessus va devenir ce sera l'an
prochain l'indice de durabilité
c'est-à-dire que désormais on va tester
aussi si un produit
pas seulement s'il est réparable mais
aussi s'il est robuste et là on se dit
parce que c'est mieux que notre appareil
ne tombe pas en panne c'est bien par le
réparer mais le mieux c'est qu'il dure
le plus longtemps possible et qui tombe
le plus tard possible en panne ouais
complètement un produit peut être
réparable mais pas durable et dans le
sens où votre produit vous pouvez le
réparer autant de fois que vous voulez
mais si derrière il y a il tombe en
panne tout le temps parce que il est pas
assez robuste parce que les pièces ça a
été assez bien conçu ou parce que il a
engrangé du travail forcé ou parce qu'il
a un impact environnemental extrêmement
élevé n'est pas durable même s'il est
réparable donc ça c'est des critères
supplémentaires que je viens de citer
qui doivent rentrer en ligne de compte
et il y a un deuxième enjeu à l'indice
de réparabilité c'est l'élévation au
niveau européen ça je tiens vraiment
beaucoup c'est que depuis l'indice de
réparabilité au niveau français le
niveau européen c'est en étant paré et
il y a une directive maintenant pour
faire un indice de réparabilité européen
et ça c'est l'accès à 450 millions de
consommateurs de enfin c'est l'accès de
ces 50 de ces 450 millions de
consommateurs à un indice de
réparabilité qui concerne
potentiellement des milliards de
produits et l'Union européenne est le
premier marché du monde et c'est là que
finit la chaîne de valeur de la plupart
des entreprises et un indice de
réparabilité assez échelle on change on
peut vraiment avoir un énorme effet
merci beaucoup donc Quentin gecker de
passer nous voir vous êtes le président
de l'association hop alt à
l'obsolescence programmée merci beaucoup
à vous et on vient de le voir les
consommateurs peu à peu avoir un peu
plus le réflexe de réparer à leur
appareil mais aura-t-on assez de
réparateur pour satisfaire toute la
demande comment être sûr de trouver les
bonnes pièces détachées reportage
signées manuels aujourd'hui 60% des
pannes d'appareils électriques et
électroniques ne sont pas réparés alors
pour y remédier depuis le 15 décembre
dernier l'État met la main à la poche
pour encourager les Français à prolonger
la durée de vie de leurs appareils et
réduire les déchets 10 à 15 euros d'aide
par réparation pour en bénéficier il
faut s'adresser aux 500 ateliers agréés
comme Murphy l'un des leaders du marché
on en voit pas beaucoup à céder comme ça
la valeur ça c'est demander en région
parisienne et tout des petits on a du
mal à en sortir mais ça fait plaisir
quand on en a Murphy répare 5000
appareils d'électroménager chaque mois
et réalise un chiffre d'affaires de plus
de 5 millions d'euros si le coût de la
réparation avec cette pas 40% du prix du
neuf en fait la plupart des
consommateurs
on va passer par la réparation au niveau
national on aura réparé 100 000
appareils en 2022 100 000 soit 0,4% des
28 millions d'appareils ménagers qui
tombent en panne chaque année face à la
demande qui explose la main d'oeuvre est
insuffisante nous on a formé on a
embauché 150 réparateurs dans les 18
derniers mois et là l'enjeu et
l'ambition c'est d'un reformer
300 dans les 18 prochains mois donc on
est sur une sur un enjeu assez
importante la France compte 5000
réparateurs sur tout le territoire alors
qu'il en faudrait le double pour faire
face à cette pénurie Murphy a pris à
bras le corps la situation en créant sa
propre école pour former les réparateurs
de demain ça peut être la carte
interface
faut bien regarder donc on va les
retrouver ou sur le schéma
pendant 6 mois les élèves alternent
entre théorie et pratiques on voit de
tout du lave-linge à la cuisson en
passant par le réfrigérateur et on
taille tout le principe de
fonctionnement des appareils
avant j'ai été restaurateur pendant 14
ans moi ce qu'il me fallait c'est un
métier qui soit utile en fait la
restauration c'est c'est bien mais c'est
pas c'est pas vital en fait c'est quand
on n'a pas d'argent on va pas au resto
quoi mais quand ta machine elle tombe en
panne tu es obligé de la faire réparer
Sébastien débutera sa carrière à 1800
euros brut par mois et pourra doubler
rapidement ses revenus si le marché
continue de s'accroître mais pour
relever le défi de la réparabilité la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre n'est pas le
seul obstacle trouver les bonnes pièces
détachées peut aussi se révéler être un
vrai casse-tête nous sommes dans la
banlieue de Lyon chez Utopia spécialiste
des pièces détachées pour téléphone
portable ici 30000 composants sont
expédiés chaque jour avec comme promesse
une livraison partout en France en 24
heures un particulier casse son
téléphone il emmène à une boutique de
réparation cette boutique là n'a pas
forcément la pièce en stock elle va le
commander sur Utopia si on n'est pas
capable nous de livrer cette pièce
détachées en 24 heures il y a des
grandes chances que vous n'alliez pas ça
réparer votre téléphone et que vous
préfériez le changer Aldric a créé
Utopia en 2013 à l'époque il livre
lui-même à vélo les réparateurs des
environs depuis l'entreprise connait une
forte croissance plus 30% en moyenne
chaque année aujourd'hui son chiffre
d'affaires frôle les 60 millions d'euros
ce qui est intéressant c'est que là tu
es sûr pouvoir faire des commandes
quasiment sans aucune erreur alors pour
honorer toujours plus de commandes en un
temps record Aldric a dû investir
quelques millions d'euros dans un
entrepôt high-tech
numéro 20 là-bas n'est pas mal plus
besoin de marcher dans les allées pour
trouver la bonne référence 25 robots
très organisés se baladent parmi le
million de pièces détachées et la porte
directement au magasinier
et toi tu es à l'aise avec la machine ça
s'est bien passé le lancement
c'est facile à prendre en main quand
même au final plus qu'on pensait non
selon Aldric la masse salariale n'aurait
pas vraiment diminué ce système lui
permettrait de limiter les erreurs de
commande de rendre la tâche plus
confortable pour le personnel
d'anticiper l'avenir et son nombre
croissant de commande problème les
fabricants ne sont pas toujours très
collaboratifs et rechignent parfois à
fournir les bonnes pièces détachées
ont du mal à vous donner les pièces
détachées
c'est une bonne question on a toujours
eu des difficultés d'approvisionnement
nous en pièce détachés d'origine on
arrive à le faire de plus en plus avec
certaines marques mais de base c'est
vrai qu'on a toujours eu des difficultés
depuis 2013 à nous approvisionner en
pièces détachées d'origine constructeur
pourtant pour les smartphones
commercialisés depuis janvier 2022 les
constructeurs sont dans l'obligation de
mettre à disposition des réparateurs une
liste précise de pièces détachées
pendant 5 ans si certains constructeurs
ne jouent pas le jeu ce serait pour la
simple et bonne raison que réparer et
moins rentable que vendre du neuf mais
aussi parce que rendre disponible
certaines pièces dévoilerait les secrets
de fabrication
[Musique]
comment inciter les fabricants en faire
plus en matière de durabilité comme on
convaincre les consommateurs de réparer
plutôt que de racheter on en parle avec
vous Enrique Martinez bonjour bonjour
merci de nous d'être le directeur
général du groupe Fnac Darty on l'a vu
c'est indice de réparabilité il était
mis en place par le gouvernement il est
obligatoire depuis 2021 je me demandais
est-ce que vous l'afficher vraiment tout
le temps dans vos magasins sur votre
site parce qu'on était juste avant avec
l'association alt à l'obsolescence
programmée qui nous disait que tous les
vendeurs tous les distributeurs ne le
faisaient pas vous le fait tout le temps
chef
il sait très bien parce que même avant
en 2018 grâce à eux il y avait comme des
Amis de la Terre on avait commencé à
s'intéresser au sujet de la réparer nos
propres antiserrer par altés sur le
monde de l'ordinateur entre autres on
trouve que c'est un élément
indispensable aujourd'hui pour donner
une information juste au consommateur et
c'est devenu un des arguments principal
d'achat des des produits et est-ce que
tous les fabricant parce que c'est ça
dépend de puisqu'il se note et ce qui
joue le jeu est-ce qu'il vous
transmettent leur note aujourd'hui les
fabricants ils sont très sensibles à des
éléments qui sont clés pour ces
consommateurs et c'est un élément qui a
quelques années probablement ça aurait
été éviter parce que c'était moins
confortable et parler des sacs et parler
de l'innovation de la technologie mais
aujourd'hui ils ont compris et
particulièrement en France parce qu'un
sensibilité il y a la législation qui
est beaucoup plus avancée que dans
d'autres pays au monde qui sont
l'intérêt des alignés à la France parce
que ça va devenir tendance mondiale donc
oui ils sont en train de jouer les jeux
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on
fabriquant Rick et Martinez nous vous
fournit pas la note d'un produit est-ce
que vous le retirez de l'étal du rayon
comme la loi le prévoit aujourd'hui
c'est une évidence que on peut pas
accepter des terribles de la loi donc
oui évidemment mais c'est pas le cas et
nous savons si ça devait arriver si ça
arrive on les faits mais aujourd'hui
nous on fait on joue avec des acteurs
mondiaux responsables et on faisait
section la sélection ça sert à ça aussi
pas seulement choisir le bon produit
mais les bons comportements de nos
partenaires et ils vont jouer j'ai
totalement confiance à eux bon vous
l'avez dit à demi-mots vous ne l'avez
pas attendu vous l'avez précédé vous
l'avez même un petit peu inspiré donc
avec le labo Fnac c'est ça tout à fait
à la performance des produits on est
quand là 2018 c'est ça 2018 et on a
commencé je me souviens qu'on avait fait
une visite avec quelques journalistes
pour les montrer les tripes d'un
ordinateur en fait nos équipes du labo
nos techniciens nous expliquer la
différence de temps et des et des
faisabilité d'échanger un batterie qui
était insérés dans 4 Liars et qui
s'apprenait une heure et demie à les
sortir ou un ordinateur qui était
impossible et d'ouvrir et donc il est
pas réparable et que ça c'était plus
acceptable alors on va voir comment vous
cherchez chez funk Darty à accompagner
les consommateurs qui veulent être plus
responsables vous avez plusieurs outils
on va les passer un petit peu en revue
il y a le baromètre SAV qu'on retrouve
sur sur Internet c'est une espèce quoi
de palmarès des produits qui sont les
plus fiables et les plus réparables en
fait on a trouvé qu'il y a une mine d'or
depuis des années parce que vous savez
on répare plus de 2 millions des
produits par an et donc on a
l'information prédictive de tout ce qui
peut arriver en produits
avec nos fabricants mais qu'on n'avait
jamais partagé avec les consommateurs et
on a dit au contraire donner on va la
partager il faut la partager il faut on
est dans le monde de la donnée du Data
c'est data c'est une data qui est riche
et hyper propre donc on va donner la
chance à tous les marques des jouets
positifs pour améliorer son escort et ça
nous permet à nous d'avoir un émulation
positive et aux marques des faire des
efforts qui payent et en quoi ce
baromètre il se différencie de l'indice
de réparabilité du gouvernement est-ce
que votre baromètre va peut-être plus
loin que l'indice il a un peu plus loin
parce que regarde aussi la fiabilité la
robustesse du produit voilà nous on va
chercher tous nos statistiques sur
la possibilité des produits après on va
intégrer en dimension des disponibilités
pour réparer un produit d'abord il faut
qu'il tombe en panne très souvent
les pièces il faut qu'il soit disponible
vraiment et dans la durée et après on va
s'intéresser aussi aux choses des prix
des pièces parce qu'en fait tout ça doit
être son ensemble il faut que la
réparation soit possible et
économiquement viable et pour tout le
monde ok il y a un deuxième outil il
faut qu'on en parle aussi qui est à
disposition des consommateurs c'est
l'étiquette choix durable on a trouvé en
magasin et l'idée c'est de mettre en
valeur un champion dans sa catégorie
c'est intéressant et c'est intéressant
parce que ça ramène aux produits et en
fait si on prend une catégorie quand les
grosses électroménagers qui nous vient
rapidement à l'esprit on en parle des
réparations aujourd'hui c'est les
premiers critères de choix d'un
consommateur face à un rayon des
produits en électroménager un
électroménager d'autres catégories
peut-être ça va arriver en deux ou un 3
parce que c'est design etc mais faut
l'électroménager la question c'est pour
combien de temps ça va durer chez moi et
donc on a dit c'est l'information qui
est relevante pour le consommateurs de
son choix il faut créer ces étiquettes
des choix durables donc si je suis
consommateur et que chez Darty j'ai deux
affichages et l'indice de réparabilité
du gouvernement et j'ai l'étiquette
choix durable c'est pas un peu confusant
c'est pas compliqué pour le client de
s'y retrouver c'est le vendeur qui va
faire les critères juste c'est
l'information qui est Darty enfin Darty
à il a fourni avant le marché où on n'a
pas attendu à bord c'est baromètre tant
mieux que ça arrive ça va permettre de
mettre tout le monde sur les mêmes
créneaux mais j'ai confiance mes
vendeurs sont capables de donner du sens
à tous ces informations qui sont pas
contradictoires ça peut être même
complémentaire et ce baromètre
cette étiquette donc c'est destiné en la
compris aux consommateurs après on
revient fabricant et je reviens à ma
question est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils font des efforts non
pas sur leur note mais est-ce qu'il
propose des produits qui sont ben voilà
plus plus réparables plus robustes il y
a une tendance vraiment tout à fait et
en fait ils ont pas des choix parce que
dès lors qu'ils sont mal placés dans ces
escorts des différentes démarques il
commence à avoir un problème des accès
au marché parce que nous en tant qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix déjà les
consommateurs
mais je pense que celles qui traînent
les pieds vont comprendre et ça paye pas
trop ils vont être obligés on le voit
dans les design des produits il y a une
forte amélioration cette dernière temps
pour rendre les produits plus réparables
et plus accessibles en fait dans les
design du produit qui est le sujet de la
réparation qui est beaucoup mieux pris
en compte qui avant et puis les sujets
de rentrer le poulet plus fiable et là
nous on contribue avec tous nos données
statistiques pour un feedback régulière
pour les advertir que certains design
particulières ils ont eu peu provoquer
des dysfonctionnements chez les clients
parfois c'est pas disponible technique
en soi c'est mauvais utilisation des
produits du client fait particulièrement
peut avoir un impact et ils sont
l'intérêt de corriger en tout cas ce qui
nous concerne à nous les produits qui
sont les moins virtuels
quelques dans quelques semaines mais je
pense que bientôt j'espère pouvoir
inviter mes partenaires pour fêter les
premiers millions et après il viendra la
deuxième et après on va continuer
aujourd'hui une deuxième millions sera
en 2023 ou plus tard on verra bien mais
déjà on va faire nos engagements des
deux mais en fait qu'on en a sorti les
programmes il paraissait impossible
parce que les choses de la réparation
c'est pas au quotidien des clients
aujourd'hui et en plus avec la crise
c'est l'inflexion ça devient encore plus
pertinent parce que tout le monde
habille les faire des économies aussi
donc si j'ai bien compris on finit
là-dessus vous êtes en train de de faire
évoluer votre modèle votre business
model comment dire en anglais chef Darty
est-ce que vous prenez pas un risque
parce que qui dit plus de réparation dit
moins de vente
donc faut que l'abonnement d'artimax
qu'on pense peut-être une baisse des
ventes si les gens rachètent pas
puisqu'il réparent regarde plus
longtemps c'est vertueux d'un point de
vue écologique mais que quand ils
viennent prise de risque chez Fnac Darty
la vie c'est un risque mais je pense
qu'il faut être dans l'heure du temps la
modernité aujourd'hui les clients comme
Darty je pense qu'il a toujours fait la
Fnac aussi c'est accompagnée pour des
produits plus de qualité il y a un
service qui accompagne les clients dans
la durée ces dernières années on a vu
arriver dans notre métier beaucoup des
mondes qui a porté par la brique service
mais que les consommateurs ils ont
accepté à avoir une vente sans service
je pense que demain ça sera plus les cas
donc même si globalement les marchés ne
pourra faire moins d'évoles je pense que
des secteurs engagés qui proposent des
services probablement ils seront en
panne des gâteaux un peu important en
tout cas c'est mon objectif c'est pas
forcément que j'ai eu d'aborder moins
c'est que les marchés faire un problème
à moins des volumes inutiles des volumes
plus des qualités soutenables et que
nous et pour un autre collègue qui vont
prendre les mêmes schémas que nous en
bas faire une partie du marché un peu
plus importante merci pour cette
entretien de Rick et Martinez directeur
général du groupe Fnac Darty voilà c'est
la fin de pourvu que ça dure l'émission
qui rend les correspondables émissions à
voir ou revoir évidemment sur Public
Sénat le replay c'est toujours sur
Public Sénat .fr rendez-vous dans deux
semaines
[Musique]
pourvu que ça dure avec le soutien déco
des déesses